[Music]
i always had an inch left i always had
some [ __ ] wiggle room
every time i would [ __ ] up there was
always some wiggle there was always a
brad pitt on the phone there was always
some like you know sundance some next
project there was always alma there was
always another there was always wiggle
room to get back into ego and this time
there wasn't no wiggle room that's why i
attribute this woman was save on my life
because she she she destroyed any route
towards that wiggle that's real it is
real rock [ __ ] bottom rock bottom
bottom isn't when you experience the
worst moment of your life bottom is when
you change
when you actually it's when you touch it
when you smell it when it's right on
your face yeah you feel it and then it's
not about severity of what the thing is
it's not it's about what you do with it
once it happens so like
once once once it happened i mean when
it landed i forgot how to breathe you
know because the email the subtext of
the email was
your hustle's over
you know
uh and i forgot how to breathe and i the
next thing i did after two minutes of
sitting there
looking at staring at a computer screen
was i went and loaded up a gun and sat
at my table and was gonna kill myself i
was out of here i didn't know what to do
anymore like all my ideas had failed and
i sat there for two minutes thinking
where is the wiggle room
i'd already used my play yeah what's the
play uh
and there were no options it was like
there was nowhere to go it's not like i
could go outside get a choco taco and
chill on the you know
people driving down the street rolling
down the window like [ __ ] off and die
you know this is where i was in the
early days of this [ __ ] so i didn't even
want to leave my house
and i had a woman living in my house who
wasn't my wife and i was on my way to go
do some movie i didn't give a [ __ ] about
you know just like momentum building
kind of [ __ ] you know movies no
intrinsic value just like i need
something on the cards you know for this
year i need my two or three products one
of these things
and um
and i felt disconnected from all of it
and i wound up getting emails from
certain dudes who who like you were
still involved in my life even when it
got ugly you know when it got chunky one
of those dudes was sean penn
sean's like you need to call brolin
and i called brolin and he told me he
was going to this meeting online now the
gun is loaded like i haven't left my
sitting position you know and i wound up
signing onto this meeting and i heard
one of the dudes who was speaking that
night say
uh
if you're new and you just entered you
know you don't have everything you want
right now but you got everything you
need right now
now
now
now
now and he did that for like two minutes
and
the first minute i'm thinking you can't
spend the whole rest of your share just
snapping your fingers and saying now
like this [ __ ] is ludicrous and i went
into this judgment which is what my
alcoholism sounds like sounds like
criticality it sounds like judgment
so i'm in my judgment like you better
say and a gun is right here i'm like you
better say something that's really going
to get me the [ __ ] out of where i'm at
and after two minutes like i i felt like
a giggle start to rise inside of me and
i felt something like presence i stopped
thinking about the email stopped
thinking about my hustle the gun almost
disappeared and it was like i'm sitting
here on this this this skype call and
i'm present for the first time in my
life and i want to write in the dude in
the chat box like hey bro you know i'm
on the verge you know i'm about to kill
myself he's like okay cool call me
tomorrow
just like throw away you know and i
needed that i've been enabled for so
long in my life that if it was gonna be
me walking into this program and having
a bunch of dudes pat me on the back like
hey man welcome home we're glad you're
here i'd have been out again because
then it would have been more wiggle room
but the guy that i wound up running into
was not having it and
he said hey man uh meet me on the beach
tomorrow and i wanna uh up here at tower
10 and he he said uh i need you to get
on your knees and i'm like i'm not
getting on my knees he's like cool
deuces he started walking away i'm
thinking oh [ __ ] but it also reified
this like you don't care
like you care but not in that way you
know you're not gonna pat me on my back
and i said okay okay i was i was so
willing at this point because i was in
so much [ __ ] pain
and he said get on your knees and i get
on my knees he gets on his knees with me
so right away it's no longer like this
power play we're like like collaborating
in this and he says i need you to stop
the waves
and i'm like
man listen this dr quinn medicine woman
version of this [ __ ] ain't gonna work
with me you know like i get how this
goes he's like are you either gonna
write what happens or you're gonna do a
bunch of [ __ ] that you don't believe in
so that your life changes because your
issue is that you you need to
rationalize everything and you're out of
options son
like what
if not this what
and he was right and so i started saying
you know stop waves and he's like louder
man stop waves and he got up off of his
knees and he started walking away and i
look back and he's like nah keep going
and he's like keep saying it again i say
stop waves he's like louder bro they're
all the way over there you're all the
way over here stop them waves man and
now i'm yelling and i'm having like an
emotional it almost feels performative
now now i'm like back in my bag back to
like the manipulating hustling like
wiggle room
yeah watch this boom let me let me and
then i'm crying and i'm stop waves you
know like uh i'm in the middle of like
the the greatest monologue of my life on
this beach
yeah exactly and uh
and uh he puts his hand on my shoulder
and he goes you can stop all that
which made me like giggle you know i
started giggling and then he stood up
and he put his hand on my left shoulder
and put his hand on my right shoulder
and he said
welcome to aaa
and uh
it did something to me that felt like
like
it felt like warrior [ __ ] i didn't i
felt like like like man code like g [ __ ]
it didn't feel like fluffy cute [ __ ]
book reading sitting in a it felt like
you're on a mission yeah it felt it felt
purposeful and it felt sexy to be honest
with you sexy in the way that listening
to kevin vance feels sexy to a young man
who feels like a boy it felt so rooted
and it wasn't emotional it wasn't
performative he wasn't trying to
manipulate me but it was kind of hokey
and like the nights with knights in
shining armor kind of hokiness that like
made me feel like a little kid again and
he said i need you to go home and clear
out like clear the decks and i'm like
nah man like
for me and i don't know if you felt this
way but every woman was the one for me
there was never a two if you liked me
you were the one
and that had to do with my insecurity
and my fear like i didn't have no there
was no two or three or i was just dating
like like frivolously it was always like
this
grand hair climbing up the
super emotional super uh romantic super
uh this fierce romance you know that i
was searching for desperate little boy
[ __ ] and he said you gotta clear the
decks and i'm like i don't know if i can
do that man you know i i feel like she's
the one and he's like giggling to
himself you know this isn't my wife my
wife is not involved in my life at this
point
and i got this one who's not the one who
accused me of this [ __ ] and she's just
another person who's who's been uh
trapped in my sphere of uh of influence
and she's living in my house and he's
like uh well look man i tell you what
you know you can keep doing it your way
or you can try some new [ __ ] because the
way that you're living it's [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] you're fully [ __ ] you're doomed
is what he said you're doomed that was
the word
and um
i flipped to this page he made me flip
to this doctor's opinion we got in our
book and in the doctor's opinions or how
our book starts it it mentions the word
doomed and he's like this isn't like
another a.a guy this is a doctor telling
you you're doomed if you don't figure
this [ __ ] out and uh he goes to put it
in perspective if you went to kaiser
permanente right now
and they sat you down and put your you
know x-rayed you and put your your x-ray
up on a light board and you were looking
at a picture of your clavicle and the
doctor said hey man you said that gray
spot just above your chest cavity you're
doomed
what would happen to you was your
[ __ ] would suck you would [ __ ]
start sweating bullets and you wouldn't
be thinking about the job that you got
to get to or the girl you got to hold on
to or where are you going to go on the
for father's day or what you immediately
your whole life would get very small and
the only rational response to that kind
of information is well what do i do
and if i told you to staple a dog's dick
to your [ __ ] chin and walk up and
down the street picking a cigarette buzz
you would do it you wouldn't ask me why
or whether you believe in it or nothing
you go look for a dog you know and so uh
that made sense to me he puts me in a
car he says i need you to listen to
sandy beach tape now at this point in my
life like i'm
i'm i'm like barely hanging on and i'm
i'm using this woman like drugs you know
every time i need validation i'm having
like i'm with this woman and and she
becomes what the job the mask of success
that the job created for me which kept
me from like really looking at myself
she became that for me in the interim
and he's like you got to get rid of all
of it you know
there is no more work and no more
romance for for a year you're going to
have to give me a year and i'm thinking
like i'm not going to be able to pull
that off you know
and right away i'm half measuring and
this is my wiggle room i i can't and uh
he says
i need you to download this tape this
sandy beach tape sandy beach is a big
speaker
uh uh
and in this in this what was the speech
yeah the speech was he's talking about
this this chinese farmer
and uh
chinese farmer in the sun they're
picking radishes about the ground and
they don't own the land that they're
farming off of
and uh they're barely subsisting they're
giving 70 to the landowner they're
living off of 30 of these radishes their
whole financial legacy is tied up into
this workhorse and one day and the sun
is really working the land because the
man is too old and one day the workhorse
runs up off the hill he just [ __ ] off
he's up the hill and the son runs into
the house and he shakes his dad up and
he says dad you're not gonna believe
this is a this is a travesty we're gonna
die out here uh i can't get these
radishes to grow unless i turn this land
over and i can't move that hoe without
the horse and the horse is gone this is
a nightmare and the old man nonplus
looks at his son he goes i don't know
what this is son i don't know if it is a
nightmare i can't call it
the son thinks his dad's out to lunch or
like ambivalent or something's wrong or
he's too old and a couple days later the
kid is chilling on the porch and he sees
the horse running down the hill with 50
wild stallions behind it
and they run into the paddock and he
locks the paddock and he runs inside and
he hits the daddy he's like man this is
[ __ ] radishes like we're rich you know
we're in the horse business we're in the
horse trading business now this is a
miracle dad i'm gonna tell everybody
we're trading horses now and the father
looks at his son nonplussed again and
says i don't know what this is i don't
know if it's a miracle i can't call it
and a couple more days pass and
the son's trying to break these horses
down domesticate these horses he doesn't
know anything about horse he's a radish
farmer so uh
one of the horses ain't having it he
rears up kicks him in his leg it's like
1400's china there's no kaiser
permanente his [ __ ] is shattered they
wrap him in some like tobacco leaves or
some sprinkle some mint on it go sit in
a chair for a while and uh
and he's wailing and the townspeople
hear about it and townspeople run up on
the little shack and oh man what are you
gonna do you know you can't domesticate
these horses you can't move this hoe you
guys are fully [ __ ] i don't know what
you're gonna do but this is this is
pretty much the end right like this is a
nightmare and the old man says i don't
know what this is he looks at his son's
leg he goes i don't know what this is i
can't really call it
uh
a couple more days pass he's sitting
with his son he's trying to calm down
he's in the middle of pain and they hear
this thunderous noise and they look up
on the ridgeline and they see
5 000 samurai on horseback running
towards their little hut and the
commanding officer gets off his horse
and says give us your son we're going to
fight the maoist army and he looks at
his son's leg and he looks back at the
samurai army and he goes
i would but he can't get out the chair
you know he
he can't get on his he can't no i can't
i would but i can he's crippled and
the man gets back on his horse and 8 000
men right off to their death
and i listen to this tape
and
and i
i'm driving back from the beach back to
where i'm living and i get out of my car
and her bags are packed
she's on her way out
and old me
would have written a haiku poem in blood
and ripped my shirt off hulk hogan's
style ran down the street and jumped
over the fence and
that guy climbed the hair up the thing
yeah yeah boombox in the air guys what i
came up on and something in me from
having heard what i just heard
what feels like this is this is now i
can't get no lower i hear this like i
can't call it and this it becomes like
this the most diplomatic breakup i ever
had in my life and i say what can i do
and and can i get you a car and she goes
no don't worry about it go get well
and i go walk into my house and i call
my dude up and i'm like man i think this
[ __ ] is working like man this is a
miracle like this is the most diplomatic
thing i ever and i'm in my meeting i'm
telling all the dudes like i think this
program is really working in my life man
and then i got five days sober and
they're like bro i think you're pink
cloud why don't you go to another
[ __ ] meeting jack
and uh
and i go on to this other meet now the
whole time i've been doing this for the
first five days i'm on the phone with a
lawyer like look this is true but this
isn't true and i got receipts for this
and i'm not gonna do this and papa
finally i'm fighting fighting fighting
tooth and nail i'm on the phone with the
agents and the manager's like listen you
gotta believe me and blah blah blah
doing that [ __ ] right
and uh my sponsor's telling me the whole
time he's like look you're gonna have to
let go dawg like the wind's at your back
just let go you know all this like
fighting [ __ ] around like let go man
that's childish
and and i'm hearing him but i'm not
doing it you know i'm on the phone i'm
on the phone with him and i'm hanging up
the phone i'm fighting this thing and i
got a lawyer who's like you need to go
to rehab for anger management because
when you go to court no spot no aa is
going to mean [ __ ] you know
addicts had already juiced that route
for so long that don't mean nothing we
need clinical receipts that you're doing
something right
and i'm like i'm not going to rehab
that's like that's
i've always really like cultivated my
brown bagger right like i don't like
wearing new shoes so this idea that i
was going to pay all this money to go
pet a horse and make a friendship
bracelet it felt like man this shit's
like that's not sexy you know i found aa
for real i'm really in my [ __ ] now i
don't want to
uh i don't want to go to this rehab
especially you don't want to go to it
because somebody's saying that's going
to get you off it's all about the
intentionality you got to not stop it's
not about not saying the right thing
because you're worried about getting
trouble you say the right thing because
you believe the [ __ ] right thing it's
that and it's also i'd already done this
right i'd already gone to rehab wrote a
script and played that game you know and
uh
and to focus
and it didn't work it didn't work it
didn't work to focus on like my
childhood trauma right isn't where my
problem lies my problem doesn't lie in
what people did to me what led you to a
place with more wiggle room and now you
don't have it and so and so and i'm i'm
telling them no i don't want to do this
you know and i'm telling a lawyer like i
don't want to do this and look yeah this
and this and i'm fighting all this [ __ ]
and i signed on to this aaa meeting
this is where i'm talking about like
miraculous [ __ ] started to pop off in my
life and my sp my dude sent me there
because his mom was taking a chip for
like 37 years and the woman who took a
chip right after his mother was the
woman i lost my virginity to
who when i was 19 years old i held a
knife to her neck
and everything in that moment it felt
like i heard god's voice say i'm
everywhere
you can't run no more
and like my whole [ __ ] all my
planning and like all this like
just went gone
and um
that really happened you know and i
remember it vividly
and i wrote her in the chat box like did
my dude tell you to come like do you
know this guy and this guy she's like
nah i'm in here because my people are
getting chips you know but it's good to
see you i knew you were on your way here
you know i i hope you get it this time
and um
so
i call my dude up and he's like bro you
got to let go
you got to let go in full and i want to
get in my car and i drive up to utah and
i'm in utah for three months and while
i'm in utah it allows me it gives me
they take my cell phone from me
and if they didn't take my cell phone
from me i was never going to be able to
deal with what i needed to deal with i
had never known how to pray because i
could never cultivate silence
i had no absence in my life every
unforgiving minute was full of some
[ __ ] scroll or some more like ego
feed constant non-stop rotation of this
this ego thing and that ego thing and
just constant fulfillment of like my own
personal desires and they took my phone
from me and just for that reason alone i
would i would
urge anybody
to go this route if you're in a
situation like mine just to get the
[ __ ] phone out of your pocket
and what that gave me was time to like
really assess what had been my operating
systems
what had been like the motivational
force in my life which was always me it
was always ego it was even the smallest
decision the smallest decision to even
go into everything to everything you eat
everything everything was ego everything
was ego i would eat that not because it
tasted good but because it would do this
or do that you know and um
so i was there for for 90 days and in
that 90 days i i uh
i made a list of all these people that i
hurt
and and um i mean a bunch of [ __ ]
happened but
uh i came out and um
just hit the ground running trying to
make amends trying to right these wrongs
this is also still a part of that
there's some people who don't want to
talk to me you know
and uh and i understand that and so my
purpose now is to be patient
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's jon
bam bam the dog
first on behalf of both of us and
everybody from the real ones team i just
want to sincerely thank you guys for for
tuning in the folks that i bring on the
show they're family to me and uh being
able to tell their stories and bringing
you into their world is something i'm
i'm just super proud of and uh again
grateful that you guys tune in we've
decided we want to take things just a
step further we're going to introduce a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become part of this
community look i already bored bam bam
if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad-free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind-the-scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot
that really brings you into the folks
that we've had on the show really brings
you into their world you're going to be
able to do live chats with me and the
folks that i bring on the show to talk
about their world talk about the issues
that they're dealing with about their
triumphs and their tragedies just go to
patreon
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
was um something about building bridges
and and bringing people together and um
bringing folks that often don't get the
mic and giving the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tune in means the
world anyways again thank you uh be good
to each other out there rock and roll